and everything is changing Moment by
moment as the shadow is passing over you
you see everything shifting and changing
and it it just it's just an incredible
and an amazing site to see yes but Joe
Joe tell us how you really feel about
this I know that's what I'm
[Music]
saying this is Star Talk Neil degrass
Tyson your personal astrophysicist got
with me Chuck Nice Chuck how you doing
man hey hey hey Neil what's happening
okay my co-host and comedian an actor so
today uh we're going to talk about
eclipses solar eclipses to be precise
nobody doesn't love a good solar eclipse
yeah and the Press is all over them when
they occur boy oh boy yeah they they
can't get enough of them and you know
there's some interesting history of
science behind solar eclipses just yeah
I thought I'd tell you about that okay
okay I'm always always down for that so
first of all eclipses these clipes
happen every couple of years they're not
rare in spite of what newspapers tell
you yeah yeah okay everybody they're not
rare yeah okay people want to think
something happens in the sky and you're
special because you're alive to see it
and they'll say then it won't repeat for
another okay yeah and it repeats in a
couple of years right but won't repeat
for your location for another 500 years
right so get in a car okay there you go
right yeah basically all right so uh in
1905 oh okay Al we go back Albert
Einstein publishes the general theory of
relativity yes which allows us to think
about uh space and time in the presence
of
accelerations all right the the original
special theory of relativity was for
constant velocity right you're not
changing your speed or Direction so it
was a simplified case and there's a
whole set of equations that go with it
but what it needed was the General case
suppose you're accelerating suppose
you're in a strong gravitational field
do these equations help you with that no
it took Einstein another 10 years to
figure out how to extend the special
relativity into the general case h 1915
he publishes the general theory of
relativity all right and what it's said
was that the fabric of space and time is
Warped in the
vicinity of strong fields of gravity in
fact it's warped in the vicinity of any
source of gravity but you only really
begin to notice it for strong sources of
gravity especially black holes which
weren't discovered yet or invented yet
but in a modern example that's the
extreme case before this the planet
Mercury
its orbit around the sun was not
following Newton's Laws H something's
wrong does does are Newton's Laws do
they fail or maybe there's another
planet right that you can't see that's
tugging on it that we're not including
in our equations well why can't you see
it oh because well maybe it's just
orbiting too close to the Sun and it's
always lost in its
glare okay so astronomers were perfectly
content explaining
Mercury's
Anomaly by invoking a planet whose
gravity was affecting it we were
perfectly happy with that we even named
the
planet we called it Vulcan oh okay oh
I right here in our own solar
system we got one right all right right
well during a total solar eclipse the
sun is blotted out by the moon right if
there's a Planet orbiting close to the
Sun you ought to be able to see it right
when you wouldn't otherwise be able to
see it under normal conditions right so
ever since we learned that Mercury's
orbit was misbehaving we waited for
solar eclipses to look for the planet
Vulcan and we never found it well it
must be behind the Sun or maybe exactly
in front of that's why know rather dodgy
V this a dodgy Planet all right so we so
we were we were happy to sort of keep
making excuses for it okay so now
Einstein's general theory of relativity
gets
published and it
predicts that light passing by the
sun will feel the gravity of the Sun and
its path will be bent as it goes by
right because of the curvature of space
and
time now now I have two things to look
for Vulcan Vulcan plus whether we're
going to bend the light around the Sun
all right so this all happened in 1915
Sir Arthur
Edington probably the world's first
astrophysicist if you wanted to we have
astronomers up until him and after that
he my boy had some Physics growing with
inside him okay so he said I'm G to test
this you say the sun has such a strong
gravity it's going to bend the I'm going
to test it so he's going to use a solar
eclipse to test it so you want to take a
picture of the Starfield when the sun is
nowhere to be found right then wait six
months now the sun is exactly in the
middle of that Starfield during a total
solar eclipse and now you take an image
of all those Stars again and see if
their positions have
shifted this is brilliant it is okay
well there's an eclipse in
1916 did he do the experiment then no
there's an eclipse in
1918 did you do the experiment then no
why
not
um 16 and 18 cause because it's like
wine an odd year is
better Chuck how soon we forget the
world was at War oh damn that's right to
resources and boats and ships and tools
and food the world was at War wow that's
right so World War I back then the Great
War as they called it because they Wars
right right right we see how that turned
out right so so the so he had to wait
for the war to end so the next eclipse
after that was
1919 so May 29th
1919 he mounts an expedition to observe
the
eclipse and he does so and he makes the
measurement of the positions of the
stars and he
discovers yes the positions of the stars
are have shifted from where you expected
them to be because they're curving in
the presence of the fabric of SpaceTime
being distorted because of the sun look
at that and people said holy cow if if
I'm Einstein's general theory of
relativity is
true then let's recalculate Mercury's
orbit and when you do that you find out
that general
relativity is what's messing up
Mercury's
orbit right you don't need so Vulcan
evaporated overnight right with the
confirmed Einstein's general theory of
relativity so a lose Vulcan we gain the
confidence in the general theory of
relativity it's all because of Sir
Arthur Edington uh brilliant physicist I
think he was from Cambridge Cambridge
England at University of Cambridge and
he's the one who said before he knew
anything about thermonuclear Fusion he's
the one who said when people asked him
well where do we get these heavy
elements he said maybe they happen in
the centers of stars well we don't think
it's hot enough in the centers of stars
and he
said maybe so but if it's going to
happen anywh in the universe it would
that's where it's G yeah I mean let's
and listen and no disrespect to Sir
Edington okay it's not a hard stretch to
make I mean well I because we we
calculated the temperatures of the
centers of stars right and it was not
hot enough to to it's not hot enough to
fuse what you know we needed we needed
quantum physics right which was the
decade that followed the 1920s right by
the way Chuck we are living in the sent
Cal
decade Centennial decade of a watershed
decade in the history of physics right
the 1920s where quantum physics was
developed where Hubble discovered that
the Milky Way is not alone in the
universe there are other galaxies and
when Hubble discovered that the universe
is expanding right all of that happened
in the 1920s wow just thought i' put it
out there that and a bunch of drinking
and
partying The Roaring 20s Roaring 20s
okay yeah not everybody was roaring you
know at the speak easys right so that's
the just bit of the background physics
on that particular it's for that reason
it's the most famous eclipse in physics
right yeah the 1919 Eclipse super cool
so Chuck you noticed that there was an
eclipse in 1916 and 1918 yeah and he got
the one in 1919 right right so like I
said eclipses aren't rare not rare okay
we're having this convers cosmologically
it's a bus schedule like
let's not get crazy let's not get
crazy okay oh my God we missed the
bus what are we going to do well we're
stuck here forever we missed it like no
man there's another one coming don't
worry we got
this buts schedule so we're we're we're
recording bits of this coming on to the
beginning of October the next eclipse is
October 14th look at that look at that
and check your bus schedule after that
go look at it right now look at it right
now all right there it is okay next one
April oh okay I mine said
420 is
that what notes are around
you okay yeah wow so look at that yeah
yeah so we we got we got eclipses coming
and going and so well I know a thing or
two about eclipses I have a friend and a
colleague who knows knows more about
eclipses than perhaps anyone else in the
world okay now how do you get to that
list I think he may be the the
person of all living people on Earth uh
oh who has seen more eclipses than
anybody else that is oh I wonder if if
anybody has attempted to um quantify
that record yeah that's that's a way to
qu so add up how many minutes in the
Moon Shadow you have lived oo that's the
title of his book
no I guess that is a book title in the
shadow of the Moon oh that's a great
title minutes in the shadow of the Moon
we'll tell him that when he when we
bring him on that's right so um yeah so
he's a friend and a colleague his name
is Joe Rayo and he's a meteorologist
he's an associate at the Hayden
planetarium at the American Museum of
Natural History and meteorologist he
actually delivered the the weather he
was like the TV weatherman for in
multiple places in the region but uh
news12 what in Long Island and I think
in Westchester but uh so by the way when
you're an astronomer you also have to be
really good at knowing the weather yes
because it's not just whether it will
rain it's whether or not there are
clouds right we care if there are clouds
right whereas you can still hold your
picnic under the clouds right so our our
standards for the weather that we need
are much higher than that basically
everybody else right so there it is uh
eclipse is here eclipse is there eclipse
is
everywhere hey start talk fans how would
you like to win a $1,500 professional
telescope for free that's right today's
episode is brought to you by veis and
they'd like to give 10 lucky audience
members their vespera telescope for free
if you don't know veas well you should
as they're the team that pioneered the
smart telescope a perfect integration of
robotized telescope and Camera all while
being controlled from your smartphone or
tablet small yet powerful and with
award-winning technology vean telescopes
Grant access to the wonders of the deep
Universe including galaxies nebula and
star clusters and are suitable for both
observation and
astrophotography even in Urban settings
as easy as 1 two three there's no need
to be an astronomy expert with Banas
ready in less than 5 minutes and compact
enough to fit into a small backpack
Von's telescopes automatically handle
all pointing tracking and focusing all
while being synced to your mobile device
so what are you waiting for head over to
vas.com sstar talk to learn more and be
Ed for a chance to wear your FR
telescope that's right fr
that's bonus.com
StarTalk V
n.com StarTalk winners will be notified
by November 3rd 2023 so Joe Chuck and I
were in conversation before we brought
you on and weren't you at one point one
of the world's leaders in how many
minutes of totality you have experienced
how many minutes in the Moon Shadow well
I I've I've experienced I've been in the
uh in the Moon Shadow for just over 30
minutes I've seen I've been to 13 total
eclipses which sounds like a lot and for
many people it is and it would have me
put it would have put me at the very top
of the list 50 years ago but I must tell
you Neil uh that uh now in the year 2023
I'm just a there are some folks
out there who have traveled to 25 30
even 35 total eclipses so I'm way way
behind the head of the pack but still i'
I've seen a decent number and have
experienced totality enough so that um
as I've always told people when you see
your very first one watch out because
you instantly become addicted and you
want to go see another one and I've I've
done that I've I've seen again more than
my fair share well did you ever did you
ever cheat and go on do you remember
they used to have the SST the supersonic
transport that would chase the the the
Shadow and you'd be like in the shadow
for an hour or something back when the
SST was running would were you ever
lucky enough to do one of those no
fortunately I have been on aircraft
which we have attempted to outra the
shadow which of course we never really
did but we were able to extend the time
of the total eclipse by a little bit uh
the the uh the Concord did in fact race
the shadow of the Moon back in 1973 and
stayed in the shadow for an incredible
73 minutes over Africa but uh of course
now we don't have the Concord anymore
and I I'm not sure whether or not any
supersonic transports are being being uh
uh developed so that we could do that
again sometime down the road but 73
minutes that's that's that's one heck of
a long who paid that gas bill God
God that was one expensive flight man
yeah so so just to put some numerics on
this so the Moon Shadow correct me if
I'm wrong Joe um is what's dragging
across Earth's surface but Earth is also
rotating in that same direction so
there's a speed of the Shadow and is the
speed of the shadow on the Turning Earth
and I always get those numbers mixed
it's about 800 miles an hour or
something is that feel about right to
you well the uh the moon and its shadow
are moving through space at about it's
the diameter of the Moon about 2,100
miles an hour and you're right when we
uh have that Moon Shadow interact with
the Turning earth right around the
equator is where the uh the Earth can
keep up with the Shadow the uh the at
the Equator the Earth is turning at
about 1,000 mph so the longest total
eclipses the ones that last 5 6 7
minutes or more those are the ones that
occur near the tropics as you uh have
eclipses that occur further north up in
the temperate latitudes or up toward the
polar regions the eclipses tend to be
shorter because the Earth just doesn't
move fast enough to keep in touch or
keep in the same path as the uh as the
shadow of the bone okay so our location
at New York we are going I we're having
this conversation in New York City at
our latitude we're going east about 800
miles hour so that you would subtract
that away from the Moon speed and that
would be the effective speed of the Moon
Shadow as it crossed over my head that
that's that's the calculation you would
do right absolutely correct a little bit
of spherical geometry coming into play
here but uh at the latitude of at the
latitude of New York there was once a
back in the 1800s I think 1806 there was
a total eclipse of the Sun that passed
over Central New York passed over
Cooperstown by the way the Baseball Hall
of Fame capital of uh of the United
States and that Eclipse lasted about
five minutes so that's about as long as
you could hope for at these latitudes at
the latitude of New York 40 or 41
degrees north is a f minute Eclipse as
opposed to being down near the tropical
areas near the equator where you can
have as long as a 7 and a half minute
total solar
eclipse in fact I the longest clip
Eclipse I ever saw was the 1973 eclipse
and I saw it on board the SS canbera at
se which was a very good place to be
because you can say oh it's going to be
cloudy where we originally targeted turn
on the engines let's go somewhere else
but if you pitch tent on the ground and
the overcast goes over you're kind of
stuck so so where did you see the 1973
Eclipse believe it or not I was not in
the totality path I was in Madrid Spain
so I had I had a I I I saw a partial
eclipse but I did not get a few of the
total eclipse of the but you were in
Spain
so you know it's kind of a watch there
bces out it balances out you know yeah
by the way by the way in in 2026 only a
few years from now a total eclipse of
the sun will be passing over Spain and
uh so that'll be a good place to see
that uh that totality I to think of it
this way I was about 50 52 or 53 years
too early when I went to Spain in
so my at for that 1973 Eclipse I was we
were close enough to the equator for
this effect to matter uh Joe and my I
saw six minutes and 19 seconds of
totality wow and which was less than had
I gone further closer to the Equator
along its path deep into Africa where
they got I think seven minutes and 20
seconds something like
that how long it was I finished a roll
of film in my camera rewound it removed
it and reloaded and finished a second
rle of film in that six minutes and 20
seconds back when film was a thing young
out there I was about to say what now
what is this film you're
talking what what is that so Joe so Joe
there are different kinds of eclipses um
tell me about uh well we know a total
eclipse the moon completely blocked the
Sun but then you know in October 2023
there's an annular clips and nobody
knows what these are could you just tell
people what it is first of all it's an
annular not an annual eclipse anular is
from the Greek ring shaped and that's
exactly what the Sun is going to morph
into at the middle part of the eclipse
it's kind of like a penny on a nickel
effect where if you think of the Sun as
the nickel and the moon as a penny the
moon on October 14th a Saturday by the
way is going to be just a little bit too
far from the earth for it to completely
cover the disc of the Sun and so when
they are all aligned the Moon is exact
aligned with the sun you will see a ring
of sunlight shining around the
silhouette of the Moon and uh that's
interesting in fact it's uh uh rather
unique if you've never seen one before
but it pales it really does it pales in
comparison to seeing a total eclipse
because during a total eclipse when you
knock out all of the Sun's light it it
really is comparing an annular to a
total eclipse is like comparing night to
day it is it is that that that that
different so so the annular eclipse is
is kind of mood
lighting just kind of let's dim the
lights
maybe put on some Barry White or some
soft music and you are absolutely right
Chuck you're absolutely right it's not
technically a partial eclipse now I I
call you know I call annular eclipses um
you know unique partial eclipses it it
is it is it is a a partial eclipse it's
nothing else uh because you're still
going to have a portion of the sun
visible and by the way during the peak
phase when you have that ring in the sky
you can't look at the ring unless you
have uh either one of those uh special
eclipse glasses or welders glass or you
could project the image of the sun
because it's dangerous it's still the
sun you're looking at absolutely where
whereas in a total eclipse in the time
the sun is totally covered there's no
sun there you remove the the the eye
protection
and there it is right right AB
absolutely so Joe you know we got
questions from our um we have patreon
supporters and I would like to go to
those they knew that you were coming on
and knew about your expertise and so
Chuck gathered them so what do you have
for us Chuck well let's go for it let's
start with uh hi Neil hi Joe hi Chuck
I'm Stephen asking from nework Ohio what
is the most
interesting thing you know about
eclipses mine is the fact that we exist
in a timeline that eclipses can occur I
appreciate it and thanks to all of you
for all you do okay so what's your most
interesting
Eclipse well you know when you've seen
13 of them each one and I said they kind
of like for me they're kind of like
snowflakes no total eclipse is alike or
similar to any other um and the most
dramatic Eclipse I think for me was one
I saw in 197 9 in Montana where we saw
the shadow of the Moon 2 to 3 minutes
before totality it looked like a tidal
wave of darkness and believe me if you
have never seen or experienced the total
eclipse before and all of a sudden
you're looking toward the Western sky
and you're looking at what appears to be
a time lapse of a severe thunderstorm of
course over you know maybe 20 30 minutes
you see the sky gradually darken as the
thunderstorm approaches but imagine now
squeezing that into a timeline of just a
couple of minutes the darkness just
charging toward you and really there's
nothing that you could do about it you
can't stop it obviously and here comes
this Shadow which suddenly just engulfs
you it's like throwing a gigantic
blanket over your head and really in the
final 30 seconds before totality it's
kind of like you know you turn down a
dimmer switch all of a sudden the sky is
dimming and all of a sudden you begin to
see the planets pop out into view
brighter Stars popping out and when that
last little bit of the Sun
disappears um and of course the Moon is
a rugged surface and so just before
totality uh you see these little beads
that are called Bailey's beads and then
one final uh uh solitire of light if you
will and with the corona of the sun
beginning to appear it looks like a
diamond ring in the sky how dramatic an
effect that is and then that goes away
you have the corona you're suddenly
enveloped in the weirdest light that
youve ever experienced in your entire
life I can't even tell you you know you
you may have seen beautiful sunrises and
sunsets and uh unusual sky colors but
there really is nothing to compare to
having totality sweep Over You All
Around The Horizon the sky appears like
a saffron uh color high above your head
kind of a navy blue in color and
everything is changing Moment by moment
as the shadow is passing over you you
see everything shifting and changing and
it just it's just an incredible and an
amazing sight to see yes but Joe Joe
tell us how you really feel about this I
know that's what I'm
saying Joe's got it real bad he's got it
bad on that one uh that was amazing so I
was in Idaho in the mountains of Idaho
in two
2017 and I looked for the shadow
approaching and it is it is scary
frightening and exhilarating all at the
same time but I have to tell you Joe
just to for others to know only when
you've seen eclipses before do you have
the luxury to not look up 30 seconds
before totality you know that there's
other stuff to notice and so you look
down and around most people in their
first time that they can't possibly
notice that Joe right well there's so
many different things that are happening
you're absolutely right Neil um about 30
seconds to a minute before there are
people who have spread a white sheet on
the ground because there are weird
looking Shadows called Shadow bands that
are flickering across that sheet um and
the reason why we see them just before
totality and right after totality is
that the sun just before totality is
suddenly a thin filament of light now
you know that when you look up at the
sky at night and you see the stars they
appear to twinkle they twinkle because
the light the little light beams coming
from the stars are passing through our
atmosphere and are being distorted by
our turbulent atmosphere so that gives
the effect of a twinkling effect now the
sun does not appear to twinkle when it's
when it's out in full view because it's
a full disc but when we have it narrowed
to a thin very thin narrow sliver of
light then the atmosphere the turbulence
of the atmosphere allows that to kind of
interfere with that uh thin sliver and
what you see there on the ground are
again really waves of light and dark
that are racing across the sheet or
racing across the ground and that's
that's an effect which you know really
is kind of there was a total eclipse of
the Sun in India back in 1980 and people
the uninitiated who were looking down on
the ground during uh the moments just
before totality they were screaming the
ground is on fire the ground is on fire
look at what's happening to the ground
it's it's just another one of these
amazing things and amazing effects that
happen right around the time when the
sun is getting ready to go away for a
relatively short interval of time yeah
so the the luxury of knowing what to
look for rather than just staring up at
the at the night sky
yeah totally to and so for me what I
like is what that can that do I get to
answer that question too Chuck do you
think yeah go ahead
oh say it like that say it like that uh
just that when you're when you're in a
uh in a lightly treed area like you have
the shade from a couple of trees and you
see these sort of dots of light this
modeling on the sidewalk I'm inan the
city so it's sidewalk the light is on
the sidewalk you so that's just light
that's just sunlight peering through no
it's more than that it's actual images
of the round sun on the sky that are
being projected through a pinhole effect
onto the ground and you know this
because if there's an eclipse going on
and you look back at that light it all
have these little
crescents and you can watch the eclipse
unfold on the ground and and Joe I saw
someone in sky and Telescope they took a
colander from from the kitchen which has
hundreds of holes on it right and then
they held that up in the eclipse and you
see all these hundreds of little Eclipse
lits can I say that Eclipse lit is that
allowed okay so that's what my favorite
part is seeing the the multiple images
of eclipses on the ground made by things
that are just otherwise Shadows of
leaves that you wouldn't otherwise know
to think about my wife and I had uh my
wife and I had dinner at a diner just
about a week ago and uh I had uh chicken
noodle soup and they brought it along
with some saltine crackers and I took
the crackers and I put it in my pocket
and she says what are you doing I said
I'm saving this for the eclipse that's
coming up because because you can can't
take you anywhere can't take you
anywhere Joe you could use you could use
a Saltine cracker which has these little
holes in it use that and project the
image of the sun through the holes and
you can there you have you know little
Eclipse projector using a Saltine
cracker yeah yeah doesn't work with a
Ritz though
huh Ritz oh do RIT have holes yeah they
do yeah but they don't go all the way
through Sal Saltines are pierced all the
way through the RIT I didn't know that
Chuck was Chuck was a cracker expert
here yeah more than more than you know
Joe let's move on to the next SC real
fast yeah yeah there you go uh by the
way uh let me just say um Neil you just
answered Justin from Ontario Canada's
question without even knowing it and he
asked the exact question of why is the
image on the ground when it's projected
through leaves and uh and he um he ended
Justin uh from Ontario Canada ended by
saying Neil you are like the stars to me
I look up to you so just just wanted to
give him credit for his question that uh
did wasn't even asked but was answered
okay all right you got it okay so um
this is Liam from Rhode Island he says
do you know if there's any effect of
solar eclipses on Wildlife I am
wondering if there have been any
interesting behaviors that have been
documented When the Sun Goes dark in the
middle of the day all right Joe what do
you got for that well we have had indeed
uh studies on that very subject in fact
in
1925 when there was a total eclipse of
the sun right here in little old New
York were uh people at the Bronx Zoo who
observed uh the animals uh who took note
the uh the deer for example raced around
in panic just before the sun uh hit
totality uh in the uh in the cage where
they kept the chimpanzees and monkeys
they were you know having all kinds of
fun jumping around everything else but
then just as totality was about to
approach they got very very quiet and
they they looked around and they almost
looked like they had a a scared look on
their face they said what what's going
on here it's getting it's getting dark
but the most interesting thing was that
there was a very rare bird called the
bird of paradise and the it it the
effect of the eclipse on that bird was
such that during the uh during the time
frame during totality the bird actually
stuck out its neck real far and extended
its wings out and just was was going up
and down up and down and the people who
study these birds never saw anything
like this before
and uh it does have an effect the
chickens go to roost in fact probably
the most famous story about this
involves Thomas Edison the great
inventor he saw a total eclipse of the
Sun in Wyoming just as you went to
Wyoming deal back in
1879 and he had a a device that he was
going to use to measure the temperature
of the corona that he had just invented
called the tasm meter and he was looking
around for a place where he could set up
and he saw an old barn housee
and he looked around there's nothing in
there and he says oh this is great and
it'll protect me from the wind and
provide me with shelter so he set his
his instrument up and here's totality
coming it's only a few seconds away and
all of a sudden from all directions
Edison got bowled over by chickens
chickens that were coming from all
directions and going back into the barn
housee or the hen house to go to roost
because they thought that night time was
was coming and so all of a sudden this
was that was one of the world's great
chicken stories I might add
there was also an eclipse that went
across near South Africa and went over
the Krueger game reserve and so there
were people who were I don't know what
results came out of that but the Krueger
game reserve were you know there's
hippos and giraffes and you know the
things that are in half the diaramas of
the American Museum of Natural History
the watering holes so I knew people were
were going there to see what the effect
is I would say the animal that behaves
the weirdest of them all is humans we
spend scads of money to to go into the
shadow take boats train planes and
Automobiles and we've got to be the
weirdest behaving creature out there the
first 30 seconds of totality as long as
the totality lasts at least 30 seconds
but the first 20 or 30 seconds people
just scream their heads off and then
then after the initial shock and the
initials screaming and yelling up look
at that look at that everybody quiets
down and and uh they have an experiment
they're they're conducting looking at
temperature sensors or whatever or
taking pictures everything gets very
quiet and then just as you approach the
end of totality you know you you start
see the interesting thing about the end
of totality there's like a red flag that
comes out that warns you that totality
is about to end the chromosphere which
is uh the uh innermost part of the sun's
atmosphere which glows kind of a
beautiful uh reddish or or or electric
pink color first begins to emerge
and that that emerges maybe about 5 or
10 seconds before the actual
chromosphere uh the the the first part
of the sun surface uh emerges and comes
back out and of course then you have to
put your glasses or your uh protective
devices back on your eyes um but it's
it's it is an amazing an amazing
spectacle literally from start to
finish Chuck give me some more okay here
we go this is will and will says
greetings Joe Neil Chuck what is the
earliest record of an eclipse and what
might have prehistoric humans thought
was going on thank you all so much for
what you do will from Lexington
Kentucky yeah any speculations there Joe
October 22nd in the year
2137 BC Believe It or Not wow we have
records of uh of of an eclipse that
occurred over China and the interesting
thing about that Eclipse uh Chuck andil
was that uh back then in those days they
actually had court astronomers now back
in 2137 they BC they could not do any
specific calculations but the court
astronomer's job was to constantly watch
the sky day and night for anything
unusual and in the case of an eclipse if
you saw that there was an eclipse taking
place you immediately alerted the
Emperor who in turn alerted the T the
the people uh who would then beat drums
or shoot Rockets up into the sky to try
to frighten the dragon they thought that
that was what in Eclipse was was was
taking place an invisible dragon eating
away at the Sun and in 2137 BC uh
unfortunately the court astronomers um
apparently were asleep either they got
drunk the night before and didn't quite
wake up in time uh and but didn't alert
anybody that an eclipse is in progress
and here comes the eclipse and here it's
getting dark and everybody's screaming
and yelling and running around shooting
Rockets they they and believe it or not
they did actually scare away the dragon
that that method that that methodology
always worked it worked every time it
worked every time but after the eclipse
was over the uh Emperor said you have
sinned an awful sin you did not warn us
about this event you didn't tell us that
the dragon was coming and eating the Sun
and so you must face the ultimate
price oh and uh they were they were
beheaded that that was it and that
presumably is the earliest record of a
total eclipse of the sun over China
again uh before the Christian era 2137
BC and of course China kept very good
records of the nights of the sky and
that's some of the best records we have
absolutely around the world going going
going far back I have a I have a case
where I someone called me at my office
and they found a diary in the Attic of
her grandfather who had just died and
that diary was of his grandfather who
was a pastor and if I my timing is right
on this I'd have to recheck my numbers
but so apparently it describes that they
are moving through Massachusetts in some
kind of Wagon Train okay and the all of
a sudden the sky got
dark and this is by the way described in
in Revelations the sky gets dark and the
pastor was certain the end of the world
was near he stopped the Wagon Train got
everybody off and said repent the end of
the world is near pray for forgiveness
everybody got off prayed then it got
light again and then they felt that
their prayers were answered so she asked
me could this have been an
eclipse and I said even deeply religious
pastors would have known what an eclipse
was because they're educated people an
eclipse is not a new weird thing in the
sky they would see it say that's an
eclipse okay so I had to conclude well
at first I went to verify that it was
real so I checked to I said when would
you she said between 1760 and 1790
Massachusetts so I went to my tables and
went to my computer found yes indeed
there was a total solar eclipse AC cross
New England uh in whatever year it was I
had the correct Year and that tightly
localized that trip
okay because eclipses are not rare but
when they do happen consecutively
they're all around the world so I nailed
that so I said yes they experienced an
eclipse but if he didn't know it was an
eclipse it must have been
overcast because overcast could couldn't
see the Sun and everything just got dark
yes everything just got dark I I
experienced that a couple of years ago I
went all I went all the way down to
Antarctica to see a total eclipse of the
Sun and uh uh down there it's almost 24
hours of daylight in December which is
the month that I went and we had total
overcast complete total overcast and uh
came the moment of
totality all of a sudden the sky got
very dark for about 90 seconds or so and
then just as quickly it got bright again
we had a gray sky but um that was the
shadow froze your buns off for no
reason you know I actually actually I
when I was offered the trip I said no
because I knew that the weather
prospects for Clear weather was was
lousy but the the the people who put the
the the tour together said you're
missing the point the eclipse is the
icing on the cake but the trip itself is
the cake how many times are you going to
get offered a chance to go to Andor so
so we went my wife and I we went we were
spent two weeks down there and I got to
tell you it was interesting I mean cting
around with we went to a place called
Paul at Island uh a one M slab of rock
200,000 Penguins on that island I mean
where and the funny thing is they they
they told us stay at least 5 meters away
from the Penguins do not go near the
Penguins somebody forgot to tell the
penguins that and in fact if you go down
to paulet Island they waddle up to you
like a pigeon will waddle up to you in
Central Park you know just looking
like so I didn't see I didn't see the
eclipse but I saw a lot of penguins okay
all right yeah that uh doesn't sound
like a good vacation
Joe was interesting I'm just going to be
honest and by the way Penguins don't
poop less than pigeons do right so
there's surely penguin poop everywhere
all right we got time for just maybe one
or two more questions Chuck okay uh hey
Neil Hey Joe hi Chuck from the world of
falible uh falsifiable hypothesis how
does a flat earther explain a lunar
eclipse from backwards Oregon expiring
minds want to
know so Joe take a stab at that I got
something to say too but I want to hear
what you I want you to lead off a lunar
a lunar eclipse is different from a
solar in that uh the the moon uh the the
sunlight provides the light that we that
allows us to see the moon reflected
sunlight when we take away that sunlight
then the moon disappears and the only we
could take away that sunlight is if the
moon were to move into a shadow our
shadow the Earth of course if we if you
believe that the Earth is a
globe like this
blasphemy and a globe will cast a a a
shadow out into space a circular Shadow
so when the moon starts moving into the
shadow of the earth you see a curved
Shadow moving across its face so if this
is a flat Earth that we all live on how
is that possible that you we we get a a
a curve Shadow moving across the disc of
the Moon and so that's that's the best
way I know to describe or to prove that
we live on a on a on a on a on a sphere
on a on a circular Planet but you left
out an important point there Joe which
is it is a curved Shadow no
matter where the moon and the sun is on
the sky during that eclipse and so you
have to ask what is the only shape that
will always give a circular Shadow and
that's a sphere whereas a disc can give
a circular Shadow but at other
orientations horizontal then it's a
straight line so that's what we would
tell flat earthers but they what they're
not gonna
listen there you go and that's the
truest lesson there which is don't waste
your
time that's the that's the real lesson
one more one more okay here what else
you got good day Dr Tyson Joe and Chuck
uh okay that's the way he says it uh so
anyway uh but then he says Andy C here
from uh Vancouver British Columbia so
maybe he's just an Aussie in Vancouver
who knows because only Aussie said good
day that's right and he spelled it good
he didn't G good anyway uh historical
question here what do we know about how
ancient and early cultur civilizations
conceived interpreted and understood
these rare events did they actually mean
something what stories and legends and
Li myths revolved around them what is
the most interesting myth or magical
moment uh associated with an eclipse
that you would know of so other than the
dragons eating eating the sun right uh
what what else is floating around there
Joe before the era of science uh there
were two Waring factions in the Middle
East the lydians and the medes they were
they were going at each other for many
many years and then all of a sudden
right in the middle of a battle the sun
suddenly darkened it a total eclipse of
the sun took place and both factions
were so frightened at what they saw they
thought that a message was being sent to
them from high above they immediately
called the truce shook hands with each
other and never wore it again it's too
bad that that can't happen today wow
that's that's a great story oh man
that's so cool I mean I just love the
idea that they're on the battlefield
going at it just like I'm going to kill
you and then this goes dark and they
like Hold
Me Hold Me Hold please hold me it's kind
like it's kind of like a game a playoff
playoff football game where both teams
are going at each other and and and
trying to you know kill each other and
then one of the players gets hurt very
seriously yeah and both and then both
teams come together that's true and they
both have their heads and they even said
I've even seen cases where both teams
pray together as the guy being carded
off the field or what it it maybe
something like that maybe maybe they
should try that prayer before the game
and they would prevent
something shut up so Joe in your your
Eclipse that took place over that battle
uh I think there's an addendum to that
Eclipse which is we know exactly where
that battle was being conducted at the
time and if you take modern Eclipse
tables and go backwards to post dict
that
eclipse the eclipse lands in the RO part
of
Earth and so you say well could they be
wrong about where they held their battle
rarely do you not know where you're
fighting other people and laying
Bloodshed so they had to correct for the
slowing down of Earth's
rotation to properly land the eclipse in
the right spot so that is one of the
longest baselines of evidence that
Earth's rotation is slowing down the
eclipse stopping that battle in that
moment at that location on Earth and so
that's the moon sloshing tides on our
Continental shelves been doing that
forever and you have to factor that in
if you're gonna back predict eclipses
into the calendar look at that yeah cool
so Joe you carry so much Eclipse
expertise um and we're doing what we can
to share it here but I understand you
offer virtual presentations on eclipses
to libraries Civics groups um
organizations and you are available to
do that before the April eclipse of next
year and from my notes Here I say it's
an hour plus of course Q&A so is so so
what what kind of things do you do in
that hour I'm offering actually two
different uh presentations one of them
is called the sky Will D the the sun
will darken on April the 8th we know why
there's a total eclipse but I get into
with a title like that though you sound
like you're trying to get the
superstitious people to
come well you know there are a lot of
people who still even to this day get
get get frightened by total eclipses but
uh we get into the mechanics of why we
have total eclipses of the Sun and then
I get into also the proper way of
observing uh eclipses especially the
partial phases where you need some uh
special device like welder's glass or uh
special uh eclipse glasses or if you
want to project it through a Saltine
cracker or through trees leafy trees uh
the other the other presentation is I
call uh Adventures of an eclipse Chase
and I talk about not all but some of the
crazy things that I've done in order to
see a total eclipse of sun for example
just one example uh a few years ago I
convinced a major airline to change
their uh the path of a commercial
airline flight from uh Anchorage Alaska
to Honolulu uh delay the flight by about
30 minutes so that we could be in the
proper position over the Pacific Ocean
so that everybody on board the flight
would be able to see a total eclipse we
would encounter the shadow of the Moon
as it passed over the Pacific Ocean and
uh this is just one of the many
different things that I've done I'll do
anything to see a total eclipse and that
was one of a version of hijacking the
airpl I was about to say you hijack the
plane you know that right say it with
the permission of the airline with the
permission so we can find you at so Rayo
is R AO so we can you at Joo weather
Gmail they can just send you an email is
that right Jo rowea gmail.com uh just
send me an email and I'll send you back
all the information about how your
library or how your Civic group can uh
get hold of me and uh excellent have me
give a presentation and I got to I think
I'm going to become a very busy person
as we get closer and closer to that big
total eclipse coming up in the spring of
next year you know when eclipses come I
hide okay so it's all you you got it
it's one day others can take over and I
can rest for a day that's how that's how
I think about it so at joeo R AO joeo
weather as in weatherman Joe raea
gmail.com Joe I'd be delighted to catch
more of you uh through those channels um
so that was that everything you never
wanted to know about in eclipse or or
never knew you could know about an
eclipse um Chuck are you are you how are
you feeling Eclipse fluent now I you
know uh yeah I'm gonna say no I still
don't there's not enough I could do more
of this to be honest oh yeah okay you
know eclipses is there anything they
can't do I mean they they they they stop
battles you know they they get
weathermen to hijack planes they you
know they behead Chinese Court Watchers
I mean all right Joe great to see you
again great to see you Neil I have a
feeling we're going to be seeing a lot
more of each other as we get closer to
the uh the big day next year we will
totally find reasons to make that happen
all right this has been another episode
of Star Talk a hybrid interview and
Cosmic queries I love them Chuck always
good to have you man always a pleasure
this has been Star Talk the grass Tyson
here as always keep looking
[Music]
up